hi elena how are you hi how are you i'm
good
good so look i know you have had time to
reflect
on everything that went down since your
eviction how are you feeling
honestly i haven't really been uh
thinking about it too much it's just
been a
flood of emotion seeing everyone in jury
catching up apologizing a lot
apologizing um so with that i'm good as
it gets honestly it is what it is it's a
game end of the day but i'm definitely
in my seals a little bit
yeah no it listen that's understandable
um you know you had a really big shock
uh when you're in the house which is
pretty cool your mom surprised you what
was it like seeing her
it was amazing i needed that especially
then it was i'm a mommy's girl so i went
into full little girl mode when i saw
her absolutely shocked i was just like
this is the best thing ever we've
watched the show together so for her to
be in the big brother house with me in
that moment it was surreal it was the
best thing ever
yeah it's a nice moment that you can
share with her and you can always look
back on um you know when you look back
on everything do you wish you pushed a
little harder to keep jc lynn around do
you think that would have changed the
game at all
i think so um i feel like i
at the beginning of it i knew keeping jc
lin would be better for my game and me
and kevin went back and forth on the
decision of keeping her or getting rid
of her but
and then i knew my heart wanted to keep
josh i just felt like it was the right
thing to do it's not the smart thing to
do and i was playing my entire game with
my head and that moment i was like i
just know
and i just knew that my heart was going
to win and i didn't so i didn't fight as
much as i should have
you know josh one head of household and
power veto in this same week do you
think he has a stronger social game or
competitive side
i would say competitive side um now
coming to jury finding out uh josh has
been very dirty he's been very personal
with everybody and lowe's social game i
thought was impeccable um actually it's
not so i think his competitiveness is
really
his actual you know strength
yeah you know you were sitting next to
your ride or die kevin uh on the block
with you know the fate of your game in
the hands of betty were you
surprised that betty chose to evict you
over kevin
i am surprised i played a better game
than her and i think especially josh
knew that and kevin knew that so betty
was going to do anything josh said and
they think that taking kevin further in
this game will be an easy win and
honestly i would agree so i don't blame
them but it does sting
do you have any strategy whatsoever
going into jury do you think you're
going to let your guard down a bit or do
you think you're going to be you know
playing a stronger game than ever
no guard is fully down in jury
apologizing left right and center and
gamer helena is left at the door and now
being my full self um but i'm definitely
going to be logical and use my head and
not my heart um i don't want to be too
biased but i'm definitely rooting for
kevin and kind of advocating for him but
very suddenly very subtly
okay so you said you're advocating for
kevin do you think kevin will take it
like if you had to predict who would
take this
is your choice kevin
kevin without a doubt would be kevin he
is my boy but he also has played such a
well-rounded game and i think i know
this jury for sure um really cares about
confidence and though kevin doesn't he
only has one win hopefully more um you
know to come but with that it's still
he's pretty overall well game overall
well-rounded and he's representing the
season in that sense it's not just about
cops
um this season i feel like we say this
with every season but this is in
particular it's been a wild ride uh if
you could describe your experience on
big brother canada season 10 in one word
what would you use
show
is that aloud i'm sorry
wild i would say wild wild no shows
hilarious and why why is that word
because you can't make this up honestly
i said it you really could the things
that happened in this game
it's all real it's just there's nothing
scripted about it it's a social
experiment you throw a bunch of people
different personalities all around
canada see what happens like just mix it
up see what happens and of course it's
gonna be good happy sad mad all of that
so
it's just a mix
well you know we still have a little bit
of this game to go so we're gonna see
who takes it what happens in jury so um
nice talking to you thank you so much
for having me